here's a here's a quick factoid i know
we have a lot of
people out there who like this kind of
stuff um what do you call a group of
otters what do you what do you call a
group of otters do you know
i don't know do you know ah
do you know you know did
a rake of otters no i did not know that
i believe that's what it's called a rake
of otters yes travis can you look that
up because i don't want misinformation
put money on
this information
that's not this type of show
well that's a tale of otter what's okay
what's a litter of otters called
no a group not a litter okay because all
right i see what you're saying it's not
like uh just it's like a vampire
land is called a romp like a school of
fish a regular waters yeah i see like i
heard you know of [ __ ]
okay this says a group of this says
they're called a romp a raft i was close
a raft
a group of resting otters is called a
rap sorry that's a rake of gypsies a
raft of jews
god damn that breitbart
you know they use
the otters
[Laughter]
gizmo
for what for what delicious treat
go ahead ian
no and i'll have actually vanilla gives
it that that um taste am i right otter
semen in vanilla travis otter semen in
vanilla
only one i think they used their that's
why they were hunting them not for the
pelts that delicious semen
okay it says it's time to stop spreading
these
it's true that vanilla flavoring is
sometimes made with the urine i thought
it was the c beaver anal gland inventory
yes flavoring oh man wow god damn it it
says that's why it's so tangy i guess
it's it's like if you're vanilla
you're really not that vanilla now
you are so english i could totally see
it
that's so
see look at that secretion called
castorium yeah out of their anal glands
flavorings and perfume so like like a
vegan is sitting there going like oh i'm
eating vegan i'm just gonna throw some
vanilla on here and it's like ah those
beaver anal plants didn't come
yeah
that's right
that's great
wow lap it up princess they they usually
process it but i like it right out of
the animals
like cow milk when it's still hot
i'm sorry everyone
who was coming up with that like who was
like you know this vanilla flavoring i
mean it's good but it needs no i think
it's like something like prairie pioneer
thing that that's like where they came
up oh they were just like [ __ ] it all we
have is this juice coming out of these
beavers anuses hey at least they really
use the whole animal that's true
you can't give them you can't say
they're throwing anything in on the way
that's the lesson to be learned oh my
god wow wow
well we do need to take a break i don't
think we're taking a break yet this
morning
could you
but this laugh train how do you slow it
down there's no brakes on this
got for that otter thing huh
dave attell is here uh the amazing david
tell you're gonna be able to see dave
december 27 through the 30th at
caroline's on broadway then uh bumping
mike's is coming to illinois then dave
is going to uh wilbur in boston foxwoods
portland maine irving california yeah
ian's on that run too oh and ian will be
with you yeah that's fantastic great
that's gonna be great uh you can go to
davidtale.com for all those dates and of
course follow dave attell uh ian is not
only gonna be on all those dates with
dave but ian will also be opening for
the pie tasters on december 26th at the
9 30 club in washington dc
and uh you can uh take a look at ian
finance on what is this
sopranos primavolta rima
volta
thursdays at 11 a.m on the not sam
youtube channel mod own